[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم سلمى الجمل
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من القدس تحديدا من
باحات المسجد الاقصى بعد انتهاء المصلين
من اداء اول صلاه تراويح في رمضان المدينه
تستقبل شهر الفضيل على وقع اجراءات
تصعيديه اسرائيليه متزايده وتحذيرا امريكي
من تصعيد التوتر وفي حلب هذا هو المشهد من
مخيم لاواء منكوبيه الزلازل في عزاز حيث
يستقبل النازحون رمضان في وقت بلغت فيه
الاحتياجات الغذائيه في سوريا على
مستوياتها منذ اندلاع النزاع وفق ما اعلنه
برنامج الاغذيه العالميه التابع للامم
المتحده ومن الرباط هذه الصور تاتينا
مباشره من احد الاسواق التي تشهد حركه
نشطه واقبالا كبيرا على شراء مستلزمات
رمضان اما هذه الصور فتاتينا من الامم
المتحده حيث
الان جلسه لمجلس الامن بشان حمايه الخدمات
الاساسيه المتعلقه بالمياه والبنيه
التحتيه اثناء النزاعات المسلحه في يوم
المياه العالمي وسنتطرق خلال جولتنا الى
ملف حرب المياه ضمن فقرات المتابعه وفي
مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
في خطوه استثنائيه واشنطن تستدعي سفيره
اسرائيل لديها احتجاجا على الغاء بنود في
قانون فك الارتباط بما يعيد فتحه مستوطنات
بالضفه الخارجيه الامريكيه تصف الاجراء
بالاستفزازي وتحذر من تاجيج التوتر خلال
رمضان نتنياهو يدافع عن التشريع باعتباره
تصحيحا لقانون تمييزي ضد اليهود وبلديه
القدس تقر خطه لبناء حي استيطاني يقطع
تواصل المدينه الجغرافي مع بيت لحم
خطوط مواجهه تتسع بين روسيا والغرب لكن
يؤكد ان الرهانات في اوكرانيا تمتد الى
اسيا ويقول ان الصين تستهدف مصالح واشنطن
بدعم موسكو الكريم الذي يتحدث عن
استراتيجيه مواجهه مفتوحه مع واشنطن جراء
تماسكها بتحليق مسيراتها في البحر الاسود
ومع استمرار سجال تزويد لندن بقذائف
اليورانيوم المنظم لافروفي يتوعد بالرد
وفقع عقيده بلاده النوويه
[موسيقى]
على الخطوط الاماميه في محيط باخموت بعد
اعلان القوات المواليه لروسيا السيطره على
سبعين في المئه من المدينه الاستراتيجيه
الشرقيه اوكرانيا وجنوبا في القرم البحريه
الروسيه تغلق خليج سباستوبل بعد هجوم
بالمسيرات
على وقع مشهد احتجاجي محتد في فرنسا
ماكرون يتمسك بتطبيق قانون التقاعد بنهايه
العام الجاري رغم اقراره بالاخفاق في
اقناع الشعب به والنقابات العماليه تتهمه
بالكذب بشان تقاعسها عن تقديم بدائل
وتتوعد بالاستمرار في التظاهر والاضراب
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا استدعاء وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه سفيره اسرائيل احتجاجا على
قانون يسمح باعاده فتح اربع مستوطنات في
الضفه الغربيه ويتيح للمستوطنين العيش
فيها الخارجيه الامريكيه اعربت للسفير
الاسرائيليه عن قلق واشنطن من هذا الاجراء
الذي وصفته بالاستفزاز الاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي ما دلالات استدعاء واشنطن
سفيره تل ابيب وقد جاءت النتيجه على النحو
التالي 7% يعتقدون انها سياسه اكثر صرامه
مع حكومات نتنياهو بينما ذهب نحو 6% الى
تحول في التعامل مع الصراع الفلسطيني
الاسرائيلي في حين راى 87% انه اجراء شكلي
لن تكون له تدعيات
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
لكبح جماح التضخم الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
الامريكي يرفع الفائده الى اعلى مستوى منذ
2006 والتداعيات تصل الاسواق العالميه
[موسيقى]
اذا في اجراء نادر واستثنائي تجاه اسرائيل
تستدعي واشنطن سفيره تل ابيب لديها فقد
قالت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه ان الخارجيه
الامريكيه استدعت السفيره الاسرائيلي
بعد الغاء الكنيست بنودا في قانون فك
الارتباط كانت تمنع الاستيطان في مستوطنات
في الضفه الغربيه نائبه وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي ويندي شيرمان اعربت للسفير
الاسرائيلي عن قلق واشنطن من هذا الاجراء
الذي وصفته بالاستفزازي واوضحت المسؤوله
الامريكيه ان من شان هذه الخطوه
الاسرائيليه ان تدفع الى مزيد من التوتري
خلال شهر رمضان واعياد الفصح اليهودي
والمسيحي يذكر ان الكنيسه الاسرائيلي صدق
على الغاء بنود في القانون بشان اربع
مستوطنات شماليه الضفه بعد 18 عاما على
اقراره ما يتيح للمستوطنين العوده للاقامه
فيها
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
دافع عن الغاء الكنيسه بنودا في القانون
واصفا ذلك بانه تصحيح لوضع تمييزي خطر على
اليهود العيش في بيوتها حظر على اليهود
العيش في بيوتهم حسب تعبيره جاء في بيان
تعقيبا على استدعاء الخارجيه الامريكيه
للسفير الاسرائيلي في واشنطن للاحتجاج على
القانون واكد نتنياهو كذلك ان حكومته لا
تنوي اقامه مستوطنات جديده شمال الضفه
ونقل موقع اكسيوس عن مسؤولين امريكيين
قولهم ان اداره بايدن كانت تفضل عدم
المواجهه مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه من اجل
التنسيق ضد ايران وتعزيز اتفاقات التطبيع
واضاف المسؤولون الامريكيون ان استدعاء
السفير الاسرائيلي كان نتيجه تصريحات وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي ومساله الاصلاح
القضائي واشاروا الى انهم كانوا يتوقعون
حدوث ازمه مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه في وقت
ما لكنهم حاولوا تاجيلها قدر الامكان
ورغم التحذيرات الامريكيه وتطمينات
نتنياهو تبدا السلطات الاسرائيليه مشروع
استيطاني جديد فقبل قليل قالت الهيئه هيئه
البث الاسرائيليه ان بلديه القدس اقرت خطه
لبناء حي السيطاني جديد سيقام جزء منه على
اراض فلسطينيه وقالت الهيئه ان موقع هذا
الحي الجديد سيكون جنوب مدينه القدس بين
مستوطنه هارحوما جبل ابو غنيم ومستوطنه
دفعات هاماتوس قرب بيت صفافه وسيضم الف
ومئتي وحده سكنيه واضافت الهيئه ان جزءا
من الحي الاستيطاني الجديد بالقدس سيقطع
تواصلها الجغرافي مع بيت لحم
ومنذ تشكيل بنيامين نتنياهو حكومته
السادسه يسود التوتر العلاقات الاسرائيليه
الامريكيه التقرير التالي يستعرض اسباب
التوتر
[موسيقى]
اقل من ازمه اكبر من توتر عابر ذلك ما
تشهده العلاقات الامريكيه الاس ايام منذ
عوده بنيامين نتنياهو الى راس السلطه
التنفيذيه وتشكيله الحكومه الاكثر يمينيه
في تاريخ اسرائيل لتصل الى حد استدعاء
واشنطن للسفير الاسرائيلي لديها مايك
هرتزوق في خطوه نادره جدا في تاريخ
العلاقات الاستراتيجيه الوثيقه التي تربط
الجانبين
استدعاء هرتسوك جاء في اعقاب مصادقه
الكنيست على الغاء بنود فيما يعرف بقانون
فك الارتباط مما يسمح بالعوده الى اربع
مستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه المحتله اخليت
عام 2005 الخارجيه الامريكيه اعتورت
الخطوه الاسرائيليه استفزازا وانتهاكا
للالتزام الذي قدمته اسرائيل لاداره
الرئيس الامريكي السابق جورج بوش قبل 20
عاما ورغم ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
تشكلت منذ نحو ثلاثه اشهر الا ان رئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن لم يوجه دعوه حتى اليوم
الى نتنياهو للقائه في البيت الابيض خلافا
لما كان سائدا اذ يسارع رؤساء الامريكيون
عاده الى دعوه رؤساء الوزراء الاسرائيليين
لزياره واشنطن بعيده تشكيلهم لحكوماتهم
وذكرت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان مسؤولين
امريكيين كبارا نصحوا نتنياهو بعدم زياره
واشنطن في الوقت الحالي اما القناه
الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه فقد ذكرت بدورها
ان نتنياهو اصدر تعليمات لجميع وزرائه
بتجنب السفر الى الولايات المتحده وتجنب
الاجتماع بمسؤولين في اداره بايدن الى ان
يدعوه الى البيت الابيض كما بدا لافته
الدعوه التي وجهها السفير الامريكي لدى
اسرائيل توماس نايلز لحكومه نتنياهو
بالضغط على المكابح في تعليق له على
مساعيها لاحداث تغيير جذري للنظام القضائي
الامر الذي رد عليه احد وزراء نتنياهو
بالقول اهتم بشؤونك الخاصه انت لست صاحب
السياده هنا مناقشه الاصلاحات القضائيه
وبعد هجوم المستوطنين على بلده حوار
الفلسطينيه جنوبيا نابلس وتصريحات وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي
الداعيه الى محوها عن الوجود وصفت
الخارجيه الامريكيه تصريحات سموتريتش
بانها غير مسؤوله وبغيظه ومقززه وقالت انه
يجب على نتنياهو رفضها والتبرا منها وخلال
زيارته لاحقا الى واشنطن لم يلتقس ايا من
المسؤولين الامريكيين كما عادت الخارجيه
الامريكيه لتصف تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي الاخيره التي انكر فيها وجود
الشعب الفلسطيني بانها ليست فقط غير دقيقه
ولكنها ايضا مقلقه وخطيره للغايه
كبير الباحثين في مركز دراسات الشرق
الاوسط
والدبلوماسيه الامريكيه السابق في اسرائيل
سيده مرحبا بك معنا خطوه غير معهوده ماذا
ارادت
اداره بايدن من وراء هذا الاستدعاء
للسفير الاسرائيلي في واشنطن
اعتقد ان الامر الاول الذي ارادوا
التحقيقه هو محاوله كبح جماح اي عنف قد
يحصل في شهر رمضان وكان هذا هو السبب
الرئيسي من وراء لقاء الشرم الشيخ وهم
راوا انما حصل هو بمثابه انتهاك
لتفاهمات شرم الشيخ هذا الامر الاول الامر
الثاني الذي ارادوا تحقيقه انه على المدى
البعيد الحكومه الاسرائيليه لا تجعلوا من
الامور اسوا وهي فعلت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وعدت الحكومه الامريكيه منذ فتره طويله
بعدم بناء مستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه لكن
الان الوقت المتحده قلقه بسبب القرار الذي
صدر اليوم على المدى البعيد وهل ينظر الى
مثل هذا القرار الذي صدر اليوم حول البناء
في القدس ليله بدا رمضان
وهو ما حذرت منه واشنطن هل تنظر اليه على
انه تحدي مثلا او لا مبالاه في المواقف
الامريكيه من قبل حكومه نتنياهو
ستنظر الى هذه المساله بشكل سلبي للغايه
هم عملوا جاهدين لكي لا تكون هناك ايه
ذرائع لوقوع المزيد من اعمال العنف بان
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين في هذه الفتره
الحساسه واشنطن ستنظر الى هذا الخطوه على
اساس ان اسرائيل وحكومه اسرائيل تقول شيئا
وتفعل شيئا في شرم الشيخ ثم تقول وتفعل
شيئا مختلفا على الارض في القدس ومثل هذا
الوضع يمكن ان يخرج عن نطاق السيطره بكل
سهوله وهم ايضا حكومه اسرائيل لا تتعامل
بشكل منصف مع هذه الامور ماذا بامكان
الولايات المتحده ان تفعله على الارض
حقيقه غير هذا الاستدعاء في حال ذهبت
الامور الى مزيد من التصعيد ماذا بيدها من
ادوات وهل بامكانها او لديها النيه في
تفعيل هذه الادوات
اعتقد ان الادوات التي تعتقد واشنطن انها
بيدها عدا عن طبعا تغيير النظام المساعدات
الامريكيه لاسرائيل وهو امر لن تفعله
اداره بايدن لكن ربما ستلجا الى المزيد من
الجهود الدبلوماسيه المكثفه
وزيارات على مستوى عالي ربما على مستوى
وزاره الدفاع الى اسرائيل اللي تخفيفه حده
التوتر والتصعيد وايضا التواصل مع السلطه
الفلسطينيه ايضا من خلال قنوات اتصال وهي
موجوده ومستمره الامر الاخر يمكن للاداره
ان تفعله هو ان تعلن بشكل علني هي اتخذت
خطوتين غير معهودتين من خلال مثلا مطالبه
المستوطنين الذين هاجموا حواره محاسبتهم
على ما قاموا به الاداره يمكن ان المزيد
من هذه الخطوات وتجعل الامور غير مريحه
لحكومه نتنياهو بشكل علني هذه الامور التي
يمكن للاداره ان تفعلها بامكان ان تفعلها
وينبغي ان تفعلها على المدى القصير نحن
قبل ان نشرع كنا قد طرحنا سؤال على موقعنا
على شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي المستطلعون
هم الفئات العربيه الجمهور العربي وكان
السؤال دلالات استدعاء واشنطن سفير تل
ابيب 87% قالوا وراوا انه اجراء شكلي لن
تكون له تداعيات الى اي درجه تنظر الى
يعني هذا المعطى من قبل الشارع العربي
تجاه السياسات الامريكيه وجديتها
ان الولايه المتحده على الاقل تحاول ان
تاخذ عين الاعتبار الراي العام العربي على
محمل الجد لكن الراي الذي تاخذه على محمل
الجد اكثر هو الكونجرس بالطبع طبعا هي لا
تحاول ان تفعل شيء قد يستفز اسرائيل امام
الكونجرس لكن تبقى هذه الخطوه
مختلفه نوعا ما لانه لم يتم استدعاء
السفير الاسرائيلي على مدى اكثر من عشر
سنوات بهذه الطريقه لهذا السبب الناس طبعا
ينظرون الى هذه الطريقه في التعامل على
اساس ان خطوه ضعيفه وما لم تتبعها خطوات
قويه واضحه فان الحكومه نفسها الحكومه
الامريكيه
حقيقه تواجه وضعا يجعلها تعتقد بان حكومه
اسرائيل لا تسيطر على الامور بشكل كامل من
وجهه نظر واشنطن شكرا لك من واشنطن
الدكتور وكبير الباحثين في مركز دراسات
الشرق الاوسط الامريكيه السابق في اسرائيل
صوت مجلس النواب الاردني بالاغلبيه على
مقترح يطالب الحكومه بطرد السفير
الاسرائيلي من عمان جاء التصويت احتجاجا
على تصريحات وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
تجاه الفلسطينيين وحديثه امام خريطه
لاسرائيل ضمت اراضي الاردن والاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله وكان الاردن قد طلب
امس الحكومه الاسرائيليه باتخاذ موقف علني
حياله تصريحات الوزير باعتبارها تحريضا ضد
الاردن
[موسيقى]
الى ساحات المواجهه التي تتسع يوما بعد
يوم بين روسيا والغرب فقد اكد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الرهانات في
اوكرانيا تتجاوزها وسيكون لها تاثير عميق
في اسيا وفي جلسه بمجلس النواب لمناقشه
ميزانيه وزاره الخارجيه قال بلينكن انه لا
ينبغي مرور عدوان روسيا على اوكرانيا دون
عقاب لان الصين تراقب كيف يتعامل العالم
مع هذا مع هذه الحرب
اذا سمحنا للعدوان الروسي على
واذا سمحنا للقوانين الدوليه
اخبرت نظير صيني بشكل مباشر بخطوره اقدام
الصين على تقديم دعم لروسيا لم نرى حتى
اللحظه
الى ان الصيناء تجاوزت ذلك الحد
اما على الجانب الروسي فكان تركيزه على
ساحه مواجهه اخرى في منطقه البحر الاسود
فقد قال نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان
قرار واشنطن مواصله تحليق مسيراتها فوق
البحر الاسود يدفع روسيا لاتخاذ اجراءات
مواجهه محذرا واشنطن من اختبار صبر موسكو
وقال الرياب كوفيد ان روسيا ستضمن انها
بكل الوسائل المتاحه واضاف ان الولايات
المتحده تظهر كل يوم رغبه في اتباع طريق
التصعيد واصفا هذا المسار بالخطير للغايات
ولافتا الى تورط الولايات المتحده بالفعل
وبشكل مباشر في الصراع باوكرانيا
في لندن قال وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس
ليفرلي ان امداد اوكرانيا بقنابل تحوي
اليورانيوم المنظم ليس تصعيدا نوويا وان
الامر يتعلق بمساعده اوكرانيا في الدفاع
عن نفسها فقط من جانبه قال رئيس لجنه
الدفاع بالبرلمان البريطاني ان قذائف
اليورانيوم المنظم تستخدم في انحاء العالم
وان روسيا نفسها تستخدمها
اما وزير الخارجيه الروسيه فقال ان بلاده
ستكون مضطره للرد على ما وصفه بالتصعيد
البريطاني بما يتماشى مع العقيده النوويه
الروسيه واضاف لابروف ان دول الغربيه
تعارض دائما معاهده تمنع استخدام الذخيره
المزوده باليورانيوم المضاده
الدوليه في جامعه بيرمنجام ومن موسكو كان
محرر شؤون الدوليه بصحيفه
برايك ما الذي يعنيه
مسار او توجهات وهواجس الاداره الامريكيه
بان الرهانات في اوكرانيا تمتد الى اسيا
سيد ديفيد
لم افهم السؤال بشكل واضح السيد انطوني
بلنكن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه قال ان
الرهانات في اوكرانيا تتجاوزها وسيكون لها
تاثير عميق في اسيا كيف نفهم مثل هذا
التوجه او الهواجس الامريكيه
حسنا نعم اذا هذه قضيه
تجعل من الاداره الامريكيه تحاول ان تحذر
من اقتراب الصين اكثر من ما ينبغي الا
الجانبي روسيا وان تتجاوز المساله مساله
التبادلات التجاريه بحيث تصبح الصين تزود
روسيا بالسلاح وهذا طبعا
يقتضي فرض عقوبات وغيرها ضد الصين لان هذا
يعني ان الصين ستدعم الغزو غير المشروع
الروسي لاوكرانيا اذا المسؤولون
الامريكيون يتابعون عن كثب هذه العلاقات
ليروا هل ستتجاوز ما هو رمزي ليصبح شيئا
ملموسا من حيث التعاون بين روسيا والصين
ما وجهه نظرك سيد ستروكان بمثل هذه
المخاوف
الامريكي عن اتساع خطوط المواجهه بين
روسيا
والغرب لتصل الى اسيا
حسنا دعوني ابدا بالقول
ان زياره الرئيس السيسي الى موسكو
والبيانات التي
صدرت عنها وردود فعل الجانب الامريكي ينظر
لها في موسكو كانها لحظات حقيقه
بامكاننا ان نقيم سلبا او ايجابا مبادره
السلام الصينيه لكن الرساله الحقيقيه هي
ان علينا ان نوقف هذه الحرب وننتقل
للتفاوض السياسي لكن الولايات المتحده
قامت برده فعل قائله بان هذه مجرد ذر رماد
في العيون ومحاوله لاطفاء شرعي على احتلال
روسيا الاراضي الاوكرانيه وهذا لا يعني اي
شيء في الحقيقه هو
هذه بمثابه
يجعلنا نعرف ونميز من يريد وقف الحرب ومن
يريد استمرارها الصين تقول ان بالامكان
الدخول في مفاوضات
وروسيا تقول نحن مستعدون لذلك طالما ان
هناك رغبه من الطرف الاخر لكن الغرب
مجتمعا والولايات المتحده تحديدا يقولون
ان الوضع ليس مناسب
للوقف الحرب وعلينا ان ناخذ الامور من
وجهه نظر اوكرانيه وهذا يعني فرض شروط
مسبقه للمفاوضات اما بقرض التعلق الامر
باسيا هذه القضيه تبدو مصطنعه لان اسيا
على بعد الاف الكيلومترات من اوكرانيا
وكذلك فان اسيا لديها ما يكفيها من
المشكلات
والقضيه كلها مختلفه فيما يتعلق باوكرانيا
لكن ما في الاسابيع والاشهر الماضيه
محاوله بشكل مصطنع
لتوسيع نطاق
مناطق سيطره لتشمل اسيا نحن لا اولا لا
نقبل بهذا الطرح هذا اولا وثانيا نحن
نعتقد ان في الوقت الذي يحاول
بالصين الوس الغرب يظهر انه لا يمتلك قوه
لمجابهه روسيا فهم يحتاجون الى المزيد من
الشركاء والحلفاء لهذا السبب مثل شرقا
بمثل هذا التحليل رايته كتبتسم خلال حديث
السيد ستروكان
واسمع تعليقك
ابتسمت لان هذه الفكره بان
الصين هو روسيا هما امتان تحبان وتعشقان
السلام اكثر من ايش في العالم
هواء روسيا هي التي تستطيع وقف الحرب فورا
بانهاء احتلال اراضي دوله دوله سياده وهي
اوكرانيا وبامكانهم ان يوقفوا عدوانهم
وايضا يتوقفوا عن هذه الاعمال غير
المشروعه وانتهاك قوانين الحرب والقوانين
الانسانيه لكن هم يحاولون ليس ذلك فقط بل
السيطره على المزيد من الاراضي وفي نفس
الوقت يستدعون دعم الصين لتطالب بوقف
اطلاق النار لكي يستطيعوا الاستحواذ على
المزيد من الاراضي الاوكرانيه فكره ان
الغرب هو المشكله واضحا
لا مره اخرى هذه معلومات
مظلله ومحاوله لاثاره الهلع من جانب بوتين
هو يعرفه ان الوضع احسن من افضل من ذلك هو
يعرف ما هي حقيقه هذه القذائف قذائف
الايرانيون المنظم عندما تاخذ اليورينيوم
الطبيعي وتستخرج منه
اليورانيوم المخصب يبقى هذه تبقى هذه
البقايا المهمله وهو ايرانيه منظم هذا
يجعل منه معدنا صعبا للغايه يستخدم في
اختراق الدروع وهو موجود في ترسانه
المملكه المتحده الامريكان وروسيا ايضا
وليس فيه سيد استروكان الخارجيه الروسيه
او لافروف
وزير الخارجيه قال بان هذا التزويد سيفاقم
بشكل خطير النزاع حسب العقيده النوويه
الروسيه ما الذي يعنيه ذلك
كما تعلمون فان
في كل المحاجات التي سمعناها حول مساله
قذائف الايرانيوم علينا ان نعود الى
التاريخ راينا في الشرق الاوسط وربما
مشاهديكم يعرفون نتائج وتداعيات هذه
الاسلحه عندما استعملت في العراق اضافه
الى يوغسلافيا المساله ليست مساله تلويث
البيئه فقط لكنها حقيقه خطره للغايه لانها
تسبب سرطانات امراض اخرى اذا هذا ضرب من
النفاق اننا بجانبا كل هذه الحقائق
المعروفه تاريخيا وهو واقع الحاله الذي
وصفناه وان نقول ان لا شيء سيحدث انا اطرح
سؤالا بسيطا لو ان محررين اوكرانيا كما
يسمون انفسهم الذين
يريدون تحطيم روسيا اذا هل سيكون في
اوكرانيا ديمقراطيه ماذا سيفعلون بالبيئه
التي هي كلها ملوثه نسيت هذه الهذا
شؤون الدوليه بصحيفه كوميرسنت من موسكو
وشكرا ايضا لضيفي من لندن ديفيدان استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه شكرا لكما
اذا في ضوء السجل البريطاني الروسي بشان
تزويد كييف بذخيره تحتوي على يورانيو منظم
وتحذير موسكو من عواقب ذلك يسلط الضوء على
استخدام مثل هذه الذخيره وما يمكنها ان
تقدمه لاي طرف ضمن المعادله التقدم
والسيطره على الارض في اوكرانيا نقترب
اكثر من الاستخدامات العسكريه
لليورانيوم المنظم في تقرير التالي
سجل بريطانيون روسي بعد ان كشفت لندن انها
ستزود كييف بقضاء خارقه للدروع بهيورانيوم
منضب الى جانب الشحنه الدبابات تشالنجر
اثنين تقول بريطانيا انه مكون معتاد ولا
علاقه له بالاسلحه النوويه وتتهم موسكو
بالتظليل لكن هذه الاخيره حددت كييف
واعتبرت ان ذلك سيعد استخدام للقنابل
النوويه القذره حيث قال الرئيس الروسي ان
بلاده ستضطر الى الرد اذا بدا الغرب
الجماعي في استخدام اسلحه ذات مكون نووي
لنقترب اكثر من هذا المكون حيث تعرف لجنه
التنظيم النووي الامريكيه اليورانيوم
المنضب بانه الذي تقل فيه نسبه اليورانيوم
235 عن سبعه اعشار في المئه من المئه
يستخدم في تقويه وتعزيز دروع الوقايه
وتشمل تغطيه الفولاذ باليورانيوم المنظم
بكثافه تبلغ ضعفين ونصف كثافه الفولاذ
العادي ويستخدم هذا النوع من الدروع مثلا
في الدبابات ام هو مدرعه
كما في طائره عشره تندر بولت اثنين
واستخدامه الاكثر جدلا في القذائف التي
يمكنها اختراق الدبابات والدروع بسهوله
اكبر حيث تصطدم القذيفه بالهدف لتحترق
ذاتيا في درجه حراره عاليه وتنبعث معها
جزيئات اليورانيوم المتناهيه الصغر في
الغلاف الجوي وعاده ما يستخدم اليورانيوم
المنظم في القذائف التي تطلق من دبابات
تشالنجر البريطانيه وابرامز الامريكيه
بالاضافه الى دبابات الالمانيه وستسلم
برلين و واشنطن عددا منها ليكييف وفقا
لمعهد الامم المتحده لبحوت نزع السلاح لا
يمكن اعتبار داخله اليورانيوم المنظم
اسلحه نوويه لانه لا يفي بالتعريف
القانونيه للاسلحه النوويه او الاشعاعيه
او السامه او الكيماويه بالمقابل يرى
خبراء البيئه والصحه العامه وجود مخاطر في
استخدام مثل هذه القذائف بسبب استنشاق
الهواء المنطلق عند الاصطدام بهدف المدرع
اضافه الى السميه اليورانيوم المنظف اذا
تسبب الى التربه على مر السنين
[موسيقى]
في التطورات الميدانيه اعلنت سلطات ودونيت
سكان مواليه لروسيا ان القوات الروسيه
طوقت باخمت بشكل شبهي كامل ونهبات تسيطر
على سبعين في المئه من المدينه واشارت
السلطات المواليه لروسيا الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه قصفت دنيا امس باكثر من 160
قذيفه ما الحق اضرارا ماديه بعدد من
المباني السكنيه ومرافق في البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه
من جهتها قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه في بيان
صادر عن مكتبها الصحفي ان الرئيس
الاوكراني فلودي مرزلينز كيزارا خلال رحله
الى رحله عمل الى منطقه دونيتس كالمواقع
المتقدمه للجيش الاوكراني في منطقه
تيباخموت واضافت الرئاسه في بيانها
نازلنسكي سمع لتقارير عن الوضع العملياتي
وسير الاعمال الهجوميه على خط المواجهه
واوضح البيان ان الرئيس يتحدث مع
العسكريين وشكرهم على حمايه اوكرانيا
والحفاظ على سيادتها لاسيما في الشرق
من جانبا اخر ذكرت وكاله الروسيه للانباء
ان خديجه سيبا ستوبل اغلق امام حركه
المرور بعد هجوم بمسيارات بحريه على
المدينه اليوم واعلن حاكم سيلفا الروسي في
شبه جزيره القرم ان اسطول البحر الاسود
صده هجوما لطائرات مسيره لم يسفر عن اضرار
او اصابات وكانت وسائل اعلام روسيه قد
ذكرت ان الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت ثلاثه
مسيرات اوكرانيه كانت في طريقها
لاستهداف خليج سيفا ستوبل
وقال وزير الدفاع الروسي ان قوات بلاده
دمرت جميع المسيرات الاوكرانيه التي هاجمت
بناء سيفاستوبل في شبه جزيره القرم جاء
ذلك خلال اجتماع في مقر وزاره الدفاع
كانت هناك محاوله لضرب مشاتنا بمدينه
سيفاستوبول بشبه جزيره القرم بواسطه
مسيرات تم تدمير جميع المسيرات وعددها
ثلاث ما اود ان الفت الانتباه اليه هو انه
تم تدمير مسيارتين من قبل البحاره الاولى
المتعاقده مارينا فاليفا والمساعده الاولى
في البحريه سيلوي كوتاتيانا اود ان اعز
بترشيح هاتين الفتاتين لنيل اوسمه وصرف
مكافاه نقديه لهما على تدمير اهداف العدو
[موسيقى]
الى فرنسا التي تعيش على وقع غضب محتدما
في الشارع بعد تمرير الحكومه قانون
التقاعد الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
وان كان قد اقر باخفاقه في اقناع الشعب
بالقانون الا انه شدد على ضروره دخول
قانون التقاعد حيز التنفيذ قبل نهايه
العام الجاري دعينا نقابات للعوده الى
الحوار
لن نسمح باي جروح للعنف وسنعمل على عوده
الحياه الطبيعيه في مواجهه البعض الذي
يعرقل النشاط علينا كذلك انا والحكومه
الاصغاء للغضب المشروع الذي لا يعني العنف
والذي عبر عنه خلال هذه الاحتجاجات اذا
كان هناك شيء اسف عليه هو اننا لم ننجح في
تقاسم ضروره القيام بهذا الاصلاح لانه
ضروري واقول للفرنسيين ان القيام بهذا
الاصلاح ليس تلفا ومتعه وانما ضروره
في المقابله تامر رئيس النقابه العماليه
في فرنسا لوران بريجيه الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون بالكذب وذلك ردا على
اتهامه نقابات بالتقاعس عن تقديم مقترح
لاتفاق مع الحكومه بشان اصلاح نظام
التقاعد وقال بيرجي ان النقاب طرحت مشروعا
لاصلاح نظام التقاعد وان فكره توحيد انظمه
التقاعد في فرنسا كانت فكرتها منذ عام
واضاف برجي ان ماكرون يزور التاريخ ويكذب
لاخفاء فشله في ايجاد اغلبيه برلمانيه
لتمرير اصلاحه غير العادل
هذا وتاثرت عده محطات لبيع المحروقات في
فرنسا بنقص امدادات الوقود بسبب عرقله
خروج الصهاريج من خزانات المصافي الفرنسيه
جراء الاضراب الذي تنفذه النقابات الرافضه
لقانون التقاعد الجديد بلغ عدد المحطات
لبيع المحروقات التي توقفت عن الخدمه
تماما بلغت 912 محطه وهي المشار اليها
بالاحمر في الخريطه بينما تعاني الف ومئت
223 محطه من انقطاع جزئي للخدمه نتيجه
نفاذ مخزوناتها من احد اصناف المحروقات
على الاقل ويشار الى هذه المحطات باللون
البرتقالي في الخريطه وبددت وبدات المناطق
الواقعه في جنوب شرق فرنسا الاكثر تضررا
من نقص الوقود
انضموا الينا من باريس باتريك فورسيا
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي سيد باتريك في
عمليه كسر العظم بين الشارع والنقابات
وبين اصرار الرئيس ماكرون ما هي المخارج
لذلك
في الواقع ثمت شيئان متناقضان فمن جهه
اليوم في بعد الظهر على التلفزيون الفرنسي
قال بان هذا القانون سوف يطبق وانه لن
يكون هناك لا استقاله للحكومه ولا تغيير
للرئيسه الوزراء ولا اي استفتاء
وبالتاليف
القانون سيمضي الى نهايته وسوف يطبق تماما
في نهايه السنه وابتل كل التفاصيل هذا
القانون ستطبق بدايه عام 2000
24 والشيء الثاني هو مساله النقابات الذين
هم لا يقبلون
لا يقبلون هذا القانون
ورغم انه جرت تصويت عليه
بفضل
الماده
في الدستور سمحت بذلك وبالتالي فهم
النقابات تحتج ضد هذه الامكانيه امكانيه
تطبيق القانون دون موافقه من الترجمه اذا
غدا فقوات الامن تقدم سيكون هناك حوالي
800 الف شخص سيخرجون الى الشوارع وهذا
طبعا رقم
كبير جدا لماذا برايك اخفق سيد
فرصه لماذا اخفق ماكرون في عمليه اقناع
الشارع الغاضب بمثل هذا التوجه لهذا
القانون وحتى النقابات
هو يقول
بانه كان انه حكام هناك تبادل الاراء كثير
بين الحكومه والوزراء واعضاء البرلمان اي
النواب الذين تقريبا هم الغالبيه منهم
ليست تماما الغالبيه لكن حتى النواب من
حزب الرئيس قد غير تناقشه كثيره حول ذلك
وقد قال ان كل شيء قد جرح احترامه ولكن في
النتيجه فان التصويت في البرلمان لم يحصل
القانون سمح للحكومه ان تطبق هذا القانون
الجديد بالقوه وبالتالي وقد قال بعد الظهر
اليوم بان هذا القانون فعلا سيطبق
وبالتالي هي كانت
مواجهه بين الطرفين طبعا لم يخرج كل الشعب
من الشوارع وبالتالي كيف
ماذا تكون نتائج هذه التظاهرات هل ستبقى
بهذا القدر الكبير انه بيمر الايام عدد
الخارجين للشوارع بعد ان يحشروا بالتعب او
الملل او الياس
الصفراء وتظاهر في شارع استمر لفتره طويله
هل من الممكن ان تكون رهانات ماكرون على
مثل هذا يعني النسيان مع مرور الوقت
ما هو مؤكد هو ان هناك احيانا بعض
المقارنه بما حصل
الصفراء لكن هؤلاء لم يكن ضمن نشاط نقابي
بل كانوا كانت تظاهرات عفويه اما الان في
هذه الحاله فان كل النقابات بكل الفئاتها
من احزاب واحزاب اليسار كلها تدعم تدعم
المحتجين وبالتالي الامر يتسم بجوانب
سياسيه اكثر مما كان الوقت في تظاهرات
الصفراء
اما الان في هذا الموضوع هناك جانب
السياسي الذي وحتى يتجاوز موضوع التقاعد
هناك امور كثيره طرحت للنقاش التي هي
بحاجه الى اصلاح وان قال اليوم بين الصغير
طرق عمله واساليبه وسيزيد من تشاوراته مع
الناس والمعنيين ولم يطلق برنامجا جديدا
ولكن
سيستخدم اساليب جديده لكي تزيير الامر على
ما يرام هو دونك قد اصطدام بين الناس
والحكومه لكن بشكل عام الناس غير محتاج
مرتاحين وهناك عدد قليل جدا من الناس
يساندون ماكرون الذي فقد الشعبيته لكن ما
الذي سيحصل في المستقبل في الواقع المشكله
الرئيسيه هي تتعلق بالشارع لان الشارع
سيستمر في التظاهر وكذلك هناك
اشكرك كان نتوقف هنا من باريس
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي عبر عن مقاطعه
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اعلن رئيس مجلس الاحتياطي الفيدرالي
الامريكي جرم باول رفع سعر الفائده بمقدار
ربع نقطه مئويه لتصل الى اعلى مستوى منذ
عام 2006 واكد باول في مؤتمر صحفي ان
التضخم في البلاد مازال مرتفعا رغم تراجعه
نسبيا عما كان عليه في منتصف العمل الماضي
نظامنا المصرفي سليم ومرن مع راس مال
والسيوله قويين وسنستمر في مراقبه ظروف في
النظام المصرفي عن كثب ومستعدون لاستخدام
جميع ادواتنا حسب الحاجه حتى يبقى سليما
ومرنا اننا ملتزمون باستخلاص الدروس مما
حدث وبالحيلوله دون تكرار ذلك مره اخرى
التضخم ما زال مرتفعا للغايه وملتزمون
بشده بخفضه الى هدفنا المقدر باثنين في
المئه
في تداعيات بعد الاعلان تراجعت السمو
اغلق مؤشر داون جونز الصناعي منخفضا بنسبه
1.6% وارتفعت العقود الاجله لخام برنت
بدولار فاصله 37 وارتفع اليورو ب
0.66% مقابل الدولار على كل للمزيد ولنفهم
اكثر الصوره ينضم الينا من واشنطن دكتور
روبرت
الخبراء في معهد السياسه الاقتصاديه سيد
سكوت مرحبا بك معنا ما الذي ارادته
الخزانه الامريكيه من وراء هذا الرفع
الخامس على التوالي
في الواقع هذه الزياده رقم تسعه في خلال
السنه الماضيه وهذه زياده اسرع زياده في
فوائد منذ اربعين عاما في الولايات
المتحده
المركزي الفيدرالي
متضايق جدا من النساء بالتضخم الماليه
خلال سنتين الماضيتين بسبب جائحه كوبيد
والمشكله الاقتصاد العالمي وحرب اوكرانيا
ولكن هذه التاثيرات بدات تتلاشى ذلك فان
البنك المركزي ما زال يضيق على الاقتصاد
وهذا سيكون له التاثيرات مدمره على على
ذوي البشر السوداء والسمراء وعلى الضعاف
الناس من ذوي الاقتصاد الضعيف في الولايات
المتحده كيف تربط بين رفع
البنك المركزي الفيدرالي
لسعر الفائده مع تداعيات ما جرى في بعض
البنوك الامريكيه
هناك عده روابط بذلك اولا زياده نسب
الفائده تؤثر بشكل مباشر على القطاع 6ثر
بالنسب الفائده مثل العقارات
والصناعات واعظم انواع الصناعات التي
استقل نشاطاتها وتزيد نسبه البطاله لدى
عامليها ورغم ذلك نشاهد ان نسبه
العماله في الولايات المتحده ما زالت
مرتفعه ولكن بمرور الزمان هذه زياده نسب
الفوائد وخاصه بهذه السرعه وبهذا الحجم
ستؤدي الى تخفيف نمو الاقتصادي وستعزل
الاقتراض اكثر كلفه للمستهلكين وللشركات
من سواء كانت قروض للسيارات او للشركات
الجديده كل ذلك سيضع ضغوطا تؤدي الى تخفيف
وتيره الاقتصاد في المستقبل القريب
شكرا لك من واشنطن دكتور روبرت سكوت كبير
الخبراء في معهد السياسه الاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
في اليوم العالمي للمياه حذرت الامم
المتحده من ان الاستهلاك المفرطه للمياه
والتغير المناخي جعل نقص المياه مستوطنا
في جميع انحاء العالم ما ادى الى خطر وشيك
بحدوث ازمه عالميه وتشكل النزاعات نزاعات
المياه تحديدا جانبا من المشهد العالمي
الراهن بسبب نوبات الجفاف والزياده
الاستهلاك وتنتشر تلك النزاعات في عده
مناطق من العالم لكن ابرزها الصراع القائم
بين دول حوض النيل لا سيما بين دولتي
المصاب مصر والسودان من جهه واثيوبيا من
جهه اخرى بعد انشائها سد النهضه اكبر
السدود في قاره افريقيا وتعتبره القاهره
والخرطوم منافيا للاتفاقيات ويضر بحصتيما
المائيتين كما تشكل المياه احد جوانب
الصراع بين العرب واسرائيل فالاردن مثلا
لا يحصل على كامل حصته المائيه من نهر
الاردن لان اسرائيل تحتكر ت المياه ومياه
الابار الجوفيه بمنطقه وادي عربه والغمر
اما بحيره طبريه فكانت من ابرز اسباب فشل
سوريا واسرائيل في ابرام تسويه بينهما حيث
تخضع البحيره ذات المياه العذبه للسيطره
الاسرائيليه الكامله ولاهميتها البالغه
ترفض تل ابيب التخلي عنها سلما او حربا
وكثيرا ما فجرت مياه نهر دجله والفرات
ازمات بين تركيا وكل من العراق وسوريا
وتقول بغداد انها اصبحت تعاني في السنوات
الاخيره نقصا مائيا حاديا بسبب السدود
التركيه المقامه على منابع النهرين وخصوصا
سد ايليسو الذي بني عند منبع نهر دجله ما
في شبه القاره الهنديه يعتبر نهر الاندوس
المعروف بنهر السند عامل نزاع قويا بين
باكستان والهند فحصه باكستان المائيه من
النهر تمر اليها عبر الجزء الخاضع من
اقليم كشمير وقد لجات الهند عام 2019 الى
وقف تدفق روافه السند الى باكستان التي
تعتبر من اكثر دول العالم نقصا في المياه
وفضلا عما يؤجزه من نزاعات تكشف ازمه
المياه في العالم عن تداعيات خطيره على
حياه الافراد والمجتمعات
فاليوم امس قال تقرير لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه ان ملياري شخص على الاقل في
العالم يشربون مياها ملوثه وغير صالحه ما
يسبب انتقال امراض مثل الاسهال والكوليرا
والتيفوئيد وشلل الاطفال
ويقدر ويقدر تقرير منظمه الصحه عدد
الوفيات الناجمه عن الاسهال كل عام بنحو
نصف مليون لاسمه في البلدان الاقل نموا
وكان تقرير الاقتصادي العربي الموحد لعام
الف لعام 2020 قد وقع انخفاض نصيب الفرد
من اتجاه العذبه في المنطقه العربيه الى
667 مترا مكعبا بحلول عام
وذلك سيكون خمس مكان عليه الحال قبل 70
عاما وكشف ايضا التقرير ان مشاريع البنيه
التحتيه لقطاع المياه في المنطقه العربيه
تحتاج الى 200 مليار دولار في الفتره بين
و25 على كلا ينضموا الينا من مدينه
اوبسالا في السويد الدكتور الشوبسوين
استاذ ابحاث السلام والنزاعات في جامعه
اوكسالا والخبير في مجال النزاعات الدوليه
حول المياه سيد مرحبا بك معنا ما خطوره ما
يجري الان من شح في المياه للاسباب
العديده التي ذكرنا جزءا منها في مناطق
نزاع هي في الاساس متوتره
نعم ان صحه الموارد المائيه اصبحت خطيره
والباحثون الذي المعنيون بهذه الامور
وصناع السياسات ورجال السياسه يتحدثون عن
خطوره صحه ونظره المياه على الاقل لاربعه
عقود الله لكنها في في بسبب تداعيات
الثغرات المناخيه زادت تفاقما الان نرى
البلدان تتحارب وتتقاتل على مصادر
المياه هناك تغيرات مع ذلك
احدثتها الطائرات المناخيه لانها هذه
التغيرات
زادت من شحه المياه وزادت من الطلب عليه
ثانيا نرى ايضا هناك تغيرا على الصعيد
السياسي هناك تحالفات سياسيه جديده تتشكل
وهذا بدوره يغير سلوكيات
البلدان تجاه اداره الموارد المائيه ما
سنراه هو اندلاع نزاعات جديده اضافه
لتفاقم النزاعات قائمه حاليا في السنوات
المقبله ونرى ايضا في بعض المناطق نظرت
وشحه المياه ستؤدي الى حروب اهليه داخل
البلد نفسه عندما نرى ان الامر مرتبط بشحه
المياه
من وجهه نظرك ومتابعتك الحديثه لهذا الملف
ملف النزاع
المتعلق اكثر بالمياه وشحها اي المناطق
الاكثر
يعني المهدده اكثر من غيرها بمثل هذه
النزاعات وتفاجرها لهذه الاسباب
صحه نظره المياه في الحقيقه
وخاصه في شمال افريقيا والشرق الاوسط
وجنوب اسيا هذه هي المناطق التي نرى فيها
ان شحه المواد المياه المائيه
يمكن ان تؤدي الى نشوب نزاعات هناك في
مناطق اخرى نزاعات كانت موجوده لكن زياده
عدد السكان وايضا هم من الناحيه المناخيه
اكثر هشاشه كذلك تاثر
الانهار الرئيسيه التي مثل
النهرين الفرات والنهر النيل وايضا هناك
عدد من هذه الانهار الدوليه لا توجد حولها
اتفاقات لتوزيعها الحصص المائيه هذا ما
يزيد من احتمال نشوب
النزاع طبعا
في الهند وفاكستان ايضا هناك مشكله حول
نهر السن اضافه الى التوترات الموجوده
اصلا لهذا السبب سنرى تكرر الازمات هي
تحدث منها الان لكن سنراها تزداد تفاقما
في المستقبل شكرا لك من مدينه اوبساله في
السويد الدكتور اوشوكس وين استاذ وابحاث
السلام والنزاعت في جامعه اوبساله والخبير
في مجال النزاعات الدوليه حول المياه شكرا
مشاركه
نهايه الحصاد بعد قليل سهرتنا الاخباريه
منتصف الليل يسحبكم بها زين العابدين
توفيق والسي ابي عاصي وفيها جوله لرصد
اجواء بدايات شهر رمضان الفضيل مع
مراسلينا في عدد من العواصم العربيه
والاوروبيه كل عام وانتم بالف خير وتقبل
الله منكم الطاعات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]